here in New York security will be very
tight for tomorrow's marathon millions
of onlookers are expected for the event
the race comes less than a week after
the terror attack on a bike path when a
truck driver killed eight people
Tony de copal is at the marathon's
finish line in New York Central Park
Tony good morning good morning shortly
after Tuesday's deadly terror attack in
lower Manhattan just about four miles
from here New York City officials
promise that the race would go on as
planned but there will be some changes
to raise security the 51 thousand
runners expected to participate will see
more blocking vehicles more sniper teams
and also more police officers both
uniformed and plainclothes thousands of
runners from around the world gathered
for the New York City marathons opening
ceremony Friday night I've been
apprehensive about running the marathon
but I also realized that I can't let it
stop me
many were excited but uneasy ahead of
the big race like New Yorker Diane
Malkin we just wanted to make it make a
point to let it be known that tomorrow
is not promised to us earlier in the day
on Friday New York City officials said
there are no credible or specific
threats against the marathon or the city
here's Mayor Bill DeBlasio there's a
sense in this city right now that it's
our job to stand up and to be unafraid
and I've seen that everywhere the New
York City Police Department said there
will be a record number of sand trucks
and other blocker vehicles to prevent a
vehicle attack on runners or spectators
chief Carlos Gomez we will have hundreds
of counter-terrorism trained officers on
the route there will be a substantial
number of explosive detecting canines on
the route we will utilize our aviation
unit to monitor the crowds the event the
race the rooftops from above on Tuesday
Saifu low say pop allegedly used a
rented truck to mow down pedestrians and
bicyclists along a bike path in lower
Manhattan killing eight people before
crashing into a school bus
this video shows a group of Argentine
friends riding on the path before the
attack of the ten men five were killed
on Friday four of the five survivors
appeared publicly for the first time
since Tuesday Hado same uncle - IDO
we are still convinced that the way to
change the world is the way we learned
when we learned as children which is
what brought us to this city to
celebrate our friendship of more than 30
years said Guillermo Ben Cheney we want
to ask that love conquers hate for our
friends our families for us for the
whole world
tomorrow morning the NYPD will open the
joint operation center which will bring
together representatives from over 20
state local and federal agencies they'll
monitor the race and make sure there are
no obstacles to get into this finish
line except for those 26.2 miles Anthony
it's only two copal thanks Tony